foreign minister Sergey lavrov says the
Wagner group's attempted Mutiny last
week will strengthen Russia the armed
Uprising against Moscow lasted 24 hours
but a Russian President Alexander
lukashenko brokered a deal to bring it
to an end
what I see of sigda is Russia has always
overcome all its problems and it's
difficult to call them anything more
than problems and it comes out stronger
and stronger it will be the same this
time too moreover we feel that this
process has already begun of more let's
speak to Yulia Chapa valova now in
Moscow so Euler the The Fallout I
suppose from the recent Wagner armed
rebellion in Russia continues
yeah yeah as uh as we here lavrov has
called brigursions Rebellion just a
trouble that will make Russia even
stronger according to level Russia's
sovereignty and its political system are
strong he particularly addressed the
issue of the presence of the Wagner
group in Africa there saying that it's
uh it's a it's um basically direct
contracts of the number of African
countries will be done with the Wagner
company and it's up to those countries
to decide whether to work with Wagner or
not and earlier he also said in an
interview with RC that a Russian
military instructors would continue
their work in Africa he noted that the
authorities of the Central African
Republic and Mali had officially appeals
to the Wagner private military company
with their request to ensure the safety
of their leadership but also hear
reports and uh Wall Street Journal
publication in particular that Russian
authorities are to take control of the
Wagner group abroad so according to the
publication few hours after the end of
preggersian's so-called March of Justice
Deputy foreign minister version flew to
Damascus to inform Syrian president
Bashar al-assad that the Wagner company
would no longer act independently in the
country and all the mercenaries were
given in order to arrive at the Russian
base in lataka it's also interesting
that Russia's opposition Medusa Outlet
citing BBC News journalists wrote that
Wagner continued to recruit mercenaries
for the Ukrainian conflict too the
journalists called the avagna PMC
hotlines in various Russian cities to
confirm that information
I knew that what has lavrov been saying
about the war in Ukraine
thank you
yeah actually uh during his media
conference the gala Brock touched upon a
wide range of issues like the conflict
in Ukraine and the problem of Ukrainian
children taken into Russia uh well apart
from progressions rebellion of course as
well as the grain deal he called kiev's
accusations against Moscow and the
Russian Federation uh that uh it's uh
the Russian Federation is allegedly
we're preparing provocations that these
Apparition nuclear power plants so
basically he called all those
accusations at pure lies lies so
regarding the conflicts in Ukraine he
said that the West is trying to freeze
the conflict for a while and by time to
pump up Kia with weapons uh speaking
about the children taken to Russia from
the war zone he said that dozens of the
children had already been found and
taken away by their parents and
relatives and according to lavrov the
Ukrainian children can return to their
parents if their parents show up
obviously and pick up their kids also
the export of Russian fertilizers
fertilizers and food continues despite
all the obstacles from the West he said
and he said that in case the grain deal
doesn't work Russia will provide
supplies to the poorest countries anyway
and it will be done at Russia's expense
and Russia is ready to supply the
required quantity of great to all those
countries and at the same time lavrov
said that he did not see any reason for
extending the grain deal and he also
spoke about U.S Laboratories in Ukraine
according to a level of Russia continues
to provide the Yuan and other
organizations with data on the
development of biological weapons in all
those Laboratories so basically that's
what Mr lavrov had to say during that
press conference
there in Moscow thank you